- [Announcer] He has won and won big,
in everything he's driven.
- Hey guys, I'm William Byron.
I drive the 24 car in
the Nascar Cup series.
(upbeat music)
I started racing when I was 15 years old.
And before that, I raced on iRacing,
which is like a computer game basically,
learned how to drive on there,
and then got started racing real cars
and have driven ever since.
(upbeat music)
Basically just get up eight o'clock, 8:30,
I go train.
It's funny my trainer,
you know he's just joking,
he's like, oh yeah you know
you just drive in circles
for a living.
And I'm like, it's definitely interesting
because that is what we're
doing, you know actually,
but there's a lot of
training that goes into it.
The training we do is
just, is all physical stuff
of trying to get your
heart rate really high
and be able to recover.
Cars get to be 140 degrees during the race
and your body really wears
down, and over time from that.
And also, you're holding
on and you're tensing up
and you're also getting pushed
by the g-forces in the car
to the right or left.
People ask a lot about like, crashes
or what's the biggest hit you've had.
Honestly, I had a pretty
big hit last year,
I hit the wall pretty hard,
got a little airborne.
You know, I've never really been injured,
I've just had you know,
soreness, things like that.
Our race cars are pretty safe.
The only difference though is like,
you don't necessarily get
hurt but when you hit a wall
it feels like a baseball
bat hit you in the stomach.
If you think about getting
hurt, I think it slows you down,
so I think if you block it out completely
and just try to focus on the race.
I think I'm the baby of the series.
We get a lot of age comments like,
oh you look so young.
And you know, I do but
it's like, it's different
to be so young but I don't
really worry about it.
When I put the helmet
on, it's kind of game on.
I mean I do school work still,
so I'm still a college student.
So that probably would
surprise some people.
You know, you have to introduce
yourself to the class,
so I kind of feel weird
talking about, you know,
I race these cars, so
it's a little different.
Yeah, I was scared of
failing my driving test.
I never parallel parked.
I use two feet when I drive
and most people you know, use one foot.
But I think it's weird
that people use one foot.
So I was worried about those two things,
I thought I was going
to fail but it was okay.
Thankfully, no, been close.
I got pulled over one
time going like 55 in a 30
or something, it was a
warning, so it's all good.
My family when we come
home for the holiday's
and we're all together, they hate the fact
that I sit in the back right seat
and I critique everything going on.
Especially after the fact,
like oh well you should've done this.
I'm a very like, task-oriented
so it's like everything
has to be done now.
And if something's like put
off, I struggle with that.
So it's like I gotta do things
and then like get done with them.
Yeah, they come to some races.
I mean, I try to get my friends
to come out to Charlotte
and some of the local places that I race.
So it's always cool to see them.
They wear the t-shirts
and look like a fan,
it's pretty cool.
Yeah, it is hard.
I mean most of my friends
are gone during the week
when I'm home, so most of my
friends outside of racing,
are kind of, you know I
see them once or twice
every few months.
But the people I know in racing,
we kind of become friends
because we're always seeing each other.
Well, I think racing,
it's kind of like golf.
You don't know how difficult it is
til you kinda get out there and do it.
So I feel like, if we could
get people in the car more,
and get them to kind of
drive, or sit next to somebody
and drive, if we could
do that to a casual fan,
it would be awesome.
Because I think it would
help them understand
what's going on.
If I have to go to the
restroom, where do I, you know,
how do I do that during the race.
Honestly, like, you get
the adrenaline going
and you don't really
need to use the restroom
when you're in the car.
But if you do, like this Nomex is okay.
But try not to.
(upbeat music)